dit que le masque aujourd'hui on est sûr
ça sert à rien à rien absolument rien et
en plus c'est dangereux
donc il n'ya pas d'études qui montrent
que ça sert à quelque chose par contre
il y a plein d'études qui montrent que
c'est dangereux donc ça suffit ce top
basta maintenant d'accord donc c'est
pour ça j'ai changé d'avis
vous l'avez dit je refuse qu'on m'a pas
tant impose le port du match alors je
refuse comme un poste le port du masque
pour moi si maintenant ils veulent se
mettre un torchon sur la tête un peu de
chance sur la tête ce que vous voulez
vous mettez tout ce que vous voulez mais
moi vous me posez rien je suis une
citoyenne de la république est en pointe
n'a pas montré que le port du masque est
utile c'est niet domicile à c'est une
loi qui a été votée elle n'est pas non
non la loi
elle n'a pas le port du masque n'a pas
été imposée par l' oms le port du masque
d'un pas été imposée par l'ordre des
médecins
moi j'aimerais savoir qui sait qu impose
le port du masque parce que tous les
organismes de santé ne l'ont pas imposé
donc est ce que c'est c'est politique
c'est quoi moi je fasse manger des
caisses déjà arrêté pour non port du
masque oui et on m'a jamais me demande
pas ce que j'explique pourquoi
j'explique que moi ma santé précieuse et
que j'estime que c'est dangereux et je
montre les études aux gendarmes
et il me dit va écouter partait qu'est
ce que vous voulez je vous dise faut
dire que les saoule je reste content
minutes alors expliquer ça
mais c'est surtout ça les contaminants
j'aimerais moi j'aurais pas envie
d'arrêter alors laurence sailly été
malin comprenait pas les antilles
maintenant mais madame en plus votre
discours mme woerth parce que si vous
voulez il ne s'agit pas de protéger
votre santé à vous il s'agit de protéger
la santé des os trouvés le et même
imaginons ce soit pas le cas il ya un
doute trouvé le temps retrouvé la dame
avec qui n'est pas comme ça je vais vous
répondre
non mais c'est pas drôle en plus pardon
avec ses façades aux diamants réa des
gens qui meurent et c'est pas drôle
ouais donc si vous voulez à après vous
avez le droit de vous exprimer
maintenant j'aime et essayé de
m'exprimer
allez-y comprenez quand même que même
s'il ya un doute et pardon on a quand
même des éléments qui nous démontre que
ça évite une provocation du virus ou
moins dans le doute pourriez vous avoir
la conscience madame de protéger les
plus fragiles les gens qui eux s'ils
sont contaminés vont mourir est ce que
vous imaginez est-ce que vous avez vu
tous ces gens âgés qui sont morts en réa
est témoin âgé aussi un accent des
congrès rue madame tous les gens en
ehpad aussi et malgré ça juste porter un
masque c'est quand même pas on vous
demande pas un truc complètement fois je
ne peux rien refusé pour ne pas protéger
la forêt un prix du net retraité
habitant propos est rien pour l année
à finir les prochains mois je n'ai pas
supporté sa peur est la peur de tout ça
soit tout de suite moi j'ai fait
des gens comme vous et j'ai jamais pour
perdre mon temps mais non pas du tout
pourquoi ces faits nous car ça nous
intéresse
elle a peur de tout et les vieux et les
machins et les jeunes et les quais
dilemme écoutez moi je souhaite remédier
aux dents mais cela finit à l'essai
stéphane issus des lycées
écoutez moi aujourd'hui il n'est
absolument pas prouvé
si vous voulez que je suis responsable
de la santé des autres ni que je suis
responsable de la maladie des autres ni
que je suis responsable de la peur des
autres mois que la culpabilité il faut
savoir un truc c'est que sur moi ça
glisse je ne suis pas dans la
culpabilité et le jeu mais pas le masque
alors stéphanie